[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est très bien coco venez dans mon
bureau
cocozvous pour peuttre faire un petit
contrat tous les
deux monsurimerais bien
chanter plaisir d'être dans la
maison alors écoute bien la son que je
vais te donner
montit
écoute
coco on tient le
Goo j'ai là pour toi un titre très très
fort qui sera disque
d' ce n'est pas du
S
du rock
r mais un tube fait main qui ne
ressemble à rien je vais mettre en
action toute ma promotion secouer les
radios éditeurs et journaux tu
verras tu seras numéro 1 au cashbox oh
il para mieux que bien numéro 1 RTL
montecal France Inter et
Europe ce n'est pas du
sol ni du rock and
roll écoute bien coco le début de
l'intro dès les premières mesures la
mélodie assure une bonne télé et nous av
gagné
tu seras
numéro mieux
bien numé
[Musique]
r écoute coco c'est vraiment ça c'est
vraiment
ça
écoute
coco on tient le gros
lot ton contrat est tapé tu n'as plus
qu'à signer on va faire une petite
bouffe pour tout
organiser j'ai déjà commander la Rolf de
cette année pour
moi tu seras numéro 1 au
cashbox par mieux que
bien 1 RTL mon France interne et
Europe numéro 1 au
casb par mieux que
bien numéro 1
[Musique]
RTL